l'arrivée de george bush à la convention
républicaine de la nouvelle orléans
regan lui a passé le flambeau bougeois
maintenant faire ses preuves début
demain
la cgt met la pression comme elle l'a
fait tout l'été dès demain journée
d'action sur les réintégrations et sur
la loi d'amnistié acte d'une première
force qui a permis à son nouveau film
sort demain il s'appelle bonjour langoat
en vedette michel serrault bonsoir est
tout d'abord la délinquance certains
faits d'actualité hélas nous rappelle
qu'elle demeure l'un des problèmes les
plus difficiles de notre société
le tragique fait divers d'annecy où des
mineurs avaient torturé et tué des
personnes âgées en fin de semaine
dernière est un exemple extrême mais
l'été fait resurgir tous les problèmes
de la petite délinquance et aussi les
efforts de ceux qui aident les jeunes à
éviter cet engrenage
un exemple la délinquance ou comment la
prévenir c'est le thème d'un spot
publicitaire qui passe en ce moment sur
les antennes vous l'avez peut-être déjà
vu vous le verrez certainement encore
dans les prochains jours question
comment passer à la télé parler à la
télé pardon des dangers de la
délinquance pascal deschamps a montré le
spot à les spécialistes et notamment un
juge pour enfants
réaction
voilà
ta vie choisi là qui est intéressant je
pense c'est que vous avez très bien
ciblé les délits que l'on rencontre le
plus souvent en matière de délinquance
des jeunes
c'est à dire le vol à l'arraché et le
vol de bécanes ou la tentative de vol la
pince quelques quelques accessoires
ces types le but du film c'est justement
de d'expliquer aux jeunes que c'est eux
et eux seuls qui peuvent qui peuvent
faire quelque chose pour entrer ou ne
pas rentrer dans la délinquance
et donc ils maîtrisent leur vie et qui
maîtrise qui mettrait georges pour la
délinquance ond qui peuvent en sortir
justement réagissant à cette prise de
conscience pour prendre du temps et
c'est un facteur important dans ce
domaine
vous qui avez reçue à des jeunes qui
sont tombés est ce que vous pensez
qu'ils ont cette angoisse de la chute
libre
je dirais qu'ils l'ont peut-être avant
est peut-être trop tort aussi et puis il
ya les actions sur le terrain le
meilleur moyen d'éviter la délinquance
c'est de proposer aux jeunes de
véritables activités et là il ya des
exemples très concrets des responsables
qui font des efforts pour que chez eux
les jeunes ne soient pas désoeuvrés tout
l'été c'est le cas de cergy pontoise
reportage anne consigny et jean-françois
chevet l'été à la croix petit près de
cergy on s'occupe ces ramasseurs de
papier sont embauchés par tilt une
société intermédiaire qui dépend de la
sauvegarde de l'enfance huit heures par
jour ils nettoient leur cité pour un
salaire de 100 francs
résultat la propre petit se porte mieux
ces jeunes respectent leur travail et
aime que les autres le respecte vous le
papier je ramasse look on dit on voit
des ti vct g qui déboule papier jeune
femme qui croupit au crédit de ramasser
puisque c'est moi qui me tient dans le
quartier moi c'était 15 ans que j'y
habite et c'est un quartier vraiment
qu'il devenait zone et qui maintenant
commence à devenir un peu plus propre
alors là on voit quand même que les
gamins pendant les vacances scolaires ne
sont pas traîner son avec des pinces à
amasser les papiers m'ont coupé les
arbustes ramasser tous les herbes salées
tout bon bain savez c'est déjà beau mais
c'est sans fanfare ce jour n'intéresse
pas tout le monde les plus vieux préfère
une autre rémunération que leurs propos
de site il être payé en heures de leçons
de conduite ou de cole comme loisir
je crois que tout droit jusqu'à rabat
vendre
son permis voisine l'a gagné loin de la
cité dans cette ferme qui travaillent
avec les éducateurs pendant quatre
semaines il a aidé au jardin semé et
arrosé planter une formule
particulièrement adapté aux jeunes de la
cité l'énergie on prend le temps
notamment pour des jeunes 13 en
difficulté le permis ça peut durer un an
dans une auto écoles classiques by
tiennent pas le choc et puis ils
abandonnent en cours de route
donc les jeunes qui démarrent le permis
avec nous en vous on est sûr qu'ils
auront permis
autre intérêt de ce travail à la ferme
il permet aux jeunes de rompre avec leur
univers urbain leur vie les jeunes de
serge ils ont choisi ronald reagan et
george bush se sont croisés à la
nouvelle orléans pour la convention
républicaine le candidat bush
attendu que regan lui passe le flambeau
pour arriver à la convention après
seulement il va venir pour tenter de
convaincre trois jours décisifs donc
pour george bush il doit montrer à toute
l'amérique qu'il est un candidat
crédible
jacques bouchard la convention
républicaine sauf un brin de toilette
entre le départ de ronald et l'entrée en
scène de genre une transition terre à
terre après l'apothéose du discours des
chants des confettis des grappes de
ballons
les républicains avaient vu grand pour
saluer au seuil de sa retraite
l'homme qui les a produit deux fois à la
victoire en huit ans
mais la convention n'est pas seulement
une grande masse et la nouvelle orléans
n'est ni chicago ni pittsburgh
la ville aime les fêtes les parades les
défilés le vieux quartier français
conserve pieusement la tradition du jazz
et des restaurants cajun avec leurs
spécialités créoles
les délégués républicains ont donc
véritablement pris possession de la
ville faisant ainsi mentir leur
réputation de notables un peu coincé
c'est d'une nouvelle version
louisianaise du congrès s'amuse les
délégués se donne certes du bon temps
mais ils attendent avec une certaine
anxiété l'entrée en scène ce soir de
george bush dans le superdome il recevra
l'investiture officielle du parti comme
candidat à la maison blanche et
prononcera un discours programme qui
sera retransmis en direct à travers le
pays c'est un test capital pour le vice
président sortant qui passe pour un
médiocre orateurs ensuite il faudra
patienter jusqu'à jeudi pour que sortent
du chapeau le nom de son colistier le
déficit commercial américain sont
chiffres pour juin était publié tout à
l'heure 12 milliards et demi de dollars
en un seul mois c'est beaucoup c'est
deux milliards et demi de plus qu'en mai
conséquence immédiate au wall street à
bessay l'ouverture tout à l'heure le
dollar lui aussi à baisser légèrement en
clôture à paris le côté 6 francs 39
alors philippe sassier l'économie
américaine allait mieux ces temps
derniers est ce que ce chiffre pourrait
signifier une rechute
non elle va toujours mieux l'économie
américaine en ce qui concerne ce chiffre
c'est vrai il est assez mauvais du mois
plus mauvais que ce que l'on attendait
d'eux question 1 est-ce que c'est tout
simplement une pause dans leur
établissement ou bien est-ce que ce
rétablissement est finie est-ce que les
amériques va retourner dans le rouge
retombé dans le rouge
pourquoi est-ce qu'on étant concernés
par ce chiffre du déficit commercial
américain
y aller les marchés boursiers les
marchés des changes sont très inquiet
actuellement de la hausse des taux
d'intérêt ils se souviennent combat
d'octobre dernier dans une atmosphère de
hausse des taux d'intérêt c'est un
mauvais chiffres commercial américain
qui a déclenché le fameux lundi noir le
krach boursier voilà pourquoi il est
suivi de très près ce chiffre alors est
ce que les élections américaines qui
auront lieu donc en novembre prochain
pourrait changer inverser la tendance
en tout cas ce sont des élections très
importante pour nous 1 à ce que
l'amérique va changer de politique
économique et faire en sorte que la
mairie glab moins s'endetter et
consommer moins deuxièmement quelle sera
l'attitude du futur président a légué
du dollar et enfin troisièmement est ce
que cette amérique va se montrer plus
protectionniste c'est ce qu'on craint
beaucoup en europe actuellement donc une
élite une élection qui est suivi de très
près par tous les milieux financiers et
industriels
merci philippe économie toujours
l'europe des 12 a accepté d'établir des
relations diplomatiques avec cinq pays
d'europe de l'est
c'était prévu c'est la conséquence
logique de l'accord de reconnaissance
mutuelle entre la cee et le comic-con
qui est le marché commun de l'est les
cinq pays et bien ce sont l'union
soviétique l'allemagne de l'est la
tchécoslovaquie la bulgarie et la
hongrie
manifestation monstre au panama au coeur
de l'amérique centrale les obsèques de
l'ancien président arias ont donné lieu
à des manifestations sans précédent
contre le gouvernement du général
noriega
plus de la moitié des habitants étaient
descendus dans la rue philippe lefait
cinq cent mille personnes dans les rues
d'une capitelle qui ont conduit 100000
du jamais vu pour les manifestants il
s'agissait de saluer en masse la mort
d'un ancien cas audio pour mieux rejeter
un autre homme fort vivant celui là le
général noriega pendant huit heures
ses obsèques ont réuni pour la première
fois dans la même contestation
les populations des quartiers pauvres
les cols blancs et quelques dames de la
bonne société
le slogan était clair qu'il s'en aille
c'est un nouvel épisode de la crise
économique et politique qui secoue le
pays depuis 14 mois selon son entourage
l'homme fort du panama ne semble pas
disposé à tenir compte du rejet
populaire qui s'exprime une nouvelle
fois cette détermination a des
antécédents
le général noriega ignore depuis plus
d'un an les pressions de washington pour
provoquer son départ
il vient de répéter à l'administration
américaine enlevez vos pattes de panama
même si la rue lui donne tort le retrait
soviétique d'afghanistan aura lieu comme
prévu moscou a annoncé que ces derniers
soldats s'en irait à la date prévue le
15 février prochain
compte tenu de la situation sur le
terrain les habitants de cisjordanie
auront des passeport jordanien mais ils
seront temporaires valables pour 2 ans
seulement c'est ce qu'ont décidé les
autorités dahmane
après la rupture des liens entre
jordanie et cisjordanie et puis au liban
l'élection présidentielle c'est en
principe jeudi il ya une pléthore de
candidats mais l'une de ces candidatures
fait beaucoup de bruit c'est celle de
soliman frangié l'ancien président
libanais il est chrétien
et surtout très favorable aux syriens
jacques merino jean max rossi
la tension est à son comble dans
beyrouth est la partie chrétienne de la
ville à deux jours de l'élection
présidentielle
multiplication des contrôles fouille des
voitures sont les signes visibles d'une
crainte générale une série d'attentats
car il semble bien que tout risque
d'être fait pour empêcher que le
parlement puisse se réunir jeudi
prochain les conditions pour être
candidat à cette élection sont simples
il suffit d'être un chrétien maronite
d'avoir plus de 35 ans est de posséder
un casier judiciaire vierge des
conditions trop simple puisque l'on
compterait aujourd'hui près de 50
candidats avoués ou pressentis parmi
ceux ci un nom polarise l'attention
celui de sleimane frangié cet homme de
78 ans président du liban de 1970 à 1976
a toutes les chances d'être élu si les
députés peuvent siéger
seulement il a contre lui le fait d'être
soutenu par la syrie et bien évidemment
pas la première milices chrétiennes des
forces libanaises que l'on voit ici
l'entraînement ne peuvent accepter
l'hypothèse d'avoir un président aussi
rien alors depuis plusieurs jours la
milice et sur lequel guerre hommes et
femmes intensifient leurs entraînements
on est là alors il faut et font de tout
mais vous pensez pas qu'il ya aussi une
façon qui est beaucoup plus classique
façon politique ou départ résister la
politique doit au début on doit on va
essayer panneaux diallo c'est ce qu'on
est en train de faire je crois qu'on va
aboutir sinon alors au revoir leur
position par la force à l'élection jeudi
prochain si la menace existe ne sera
peut être pas nécessaire car il ya bien
peu de chances que les députés sont
assez nombreux le 18 août à se déplacer
pour aller voter pour élire le président
il faut un quorum des deux tiers du
parlement
nelson mandela est atteint de
tuberculose c'est ce qu'a dit tout à
l'heure l'avocat du leader noir sud
africain
l'avocat accompagner ce matin winnie
mandela la femme et la fille du leader
noir à la prison de pulse mort près du
cap où nelson mandela est retenu depuis
1962 là maintenant 70 ans
son état s'est détérioré selon son
avocat en france demain timide reprise
de l'actualité politique avec le conseil
des ministres c'est le conseil de
reprise après les vacances du
gouvernement
demain aussi début des discussions à
paris sur la nouvelle calédonie au
ministère des dom tom
les deux délégations du rpcr et du fln
cas elles vont se retrouver
objectif trouver un accord final sur
l'avenir du territoire
rachid arhab jacques lafleur croisant
jean marie tjibaou à l'aéroport de
nouméa
les deux hommes échangent d'une
plaisanterie et ce quitte ce matin jean
marie tjibaou prenez l'avion à la tête
d'une délégation du fln ks une
délégation qui ne vient pas d'après son
président faire un matignon bis mais qui
espère conclure un accord dans de bonnes
conditions pour les uns et les autres
jean marie tjibaou confiant côté rpcr
jacques lafleur souffrant de difficultés
cardiaques n'est pas du voyage
le leader anti indépendantistes étaient
un peu méfiant ce matin à nouméa
ce sera l'aboutissement les accords dits
de matignon ce sport et les n'y aura
aucune modification aucune riches
les deux délégations voyage ensemble
dans l'avion il ne manque guère que les
indépendantistes dur du fût qu'une
composante minoritaire du fn heynckes
une absence qui ne pèsera pas très lourd
dans les conversations à paris le
responsable du flq yann cdéné uregei
resté à nouméa et souvent en conflit
avec jean marie tjibaou
jean marie tjibaou qui semble avoir
réussi à fléchir les durs de son
mouvement le fln caisse vient
apparemment à paris avec des positions
assez souple pour discuter l'été chaud
de la cgt demain une journée d'action la
revendication que la loi d'amnistié
réintègre dans leurs fonctions tous les
licenciés dans les entreprises
tout le monde vous le savez parle d'une
rentrée sociale difficile
la cgt elle a maintenu la pression tout
l'été nicolas jacobs et intégration des
militants licencié ce sera demain le mot
d'ordre que mettra en avant la cgt pour
sa rentrée sociale très en avance dans
le calendrier mais à vrai dire la cgt a
occupé le terrain tout l'été en juillet
par exemple à l'imprimerie didier
conflits très durs heurts violents avec
les milices patronales dramatisation
maximum à l'origine du conflit le
licenciement de deux employés de plus 22
autres dont 19 cégétiste sont menacés en
six semaines ce sera le bras de fer
entre un patron de choc qui veut se
débarrasser de ce qu'il estime être
responsable du désordre et un syndicat
qui veut faire la démonstration de sa
puissance dans ce secteur la cgt par
viendra d'ailleurs imposé ses vues
autres revendications mises en avant les
salaires à gardanne pendant quatre mois
les mines sont paralysés après s'être
serré la ceinture gagner en productivité
les mineurs réclament des augmentations
de salaires cgt cfdt en cause commune
mais quand ce syndicat propose de
consulter les grévistes sur une
éventuelle reprise du travail c'est la
rupture violente et la cgt men seul le
conflit juste
au bout sans vraiment obtenir
satisfaction mais en ayant montré que
c'est elle qui menait les luttes et
encore elle qui mettait un terme la côte
d'azur à 100 ans
bien sûr la côte d'azur existait avant
que vous vous en doutez mais cela fait
sens tant qu'on l'appelle comme ça
d'où cette année 88 toute une série de
célébrations mais la côte d'azur ce ne
sont pas seulement les festivals et les
expos les plages et les hôtels de luxe
la côte d'azur c'est aussi la deuxième
région économique de france il faut le
savoir des industries qui vont des
traditionnels parfum à l'informatique la
plus moderne
alain douguet ski daniel levy reportage
trouver un clown à sophia antipolis des
ingénieurs du communique avec tous les
clients européens de leur société
digital équipements à grasse un homme
dont le travail consiste à inventer les
parfums entre deux siècles d'industrie
sur la côte d'azur
aujourd'hui créativité productivité ont
mis le cap au sud
affirmer responsable exemple chez
digital des hommes des femmes vont
communiquer avec l'europe entière faire
ce que l'on appelle des télédiagnostic
un ordinateur digital est en panne à
oslo un homme parlant norvégien va
connecter téléphoniquement un des
ordinateurs niçois à celui d'oslo
viva l'ausculter trouver la panne et
cela jour et nuit toute l'année
digital été un pionnier dans le domaine
du télédiagnostic il n'y en oeuvre des
techniques sophistiquées comme
l'intelligence artificielle et ceci nous
permet de diagnostiquer des réseaux les
systèmes de plus en plus complexes ils
étaient seuls au monde à faire ça les
selon nous avons été les pionniers et
nous restons les pieds ni la semaine
revenons à grasse depuis deux siècles on
y invente on y fabrique des parfums
il existe plus de six mille essences
différentes sur la palette des créateurs
la production régionale représente les
deux tiers de la production française
tous pour cent de la production mondiale
dès la fin du 19e siècle les parfumeurs
français se sont imposés comme les
arbitres du bon goût en la matière les
années passent les récoltes de fleurs ne
suffisent plus apparaît alors la chimie
de synthèse mutation adaptation de tous
les industriels de la région
la capitale des parfums restera grâce
l'investigation a su prendre le virage
qu'il fallait à l'époque qu'il fallait
et actuellement les usines de
partenaires sont toutes une femme
moderne est donc parfaitement dans le
vent dans la course sans problème des
usines sous les palmiers des ateliers
parmi les fleurs soleil industries font
bon ménage
la preuve ils s'implantent cinq
entreprises par mois dans la région
le chiffre d'affaires industriel dépasse
les 10 milliards de francs
autant que celui du tourisme voilà cette
information dont je viens de prendre
connaissance à l'instant deux
prisonniers palestiniens ont été tués
par des gardiens israélien ça s'est
passé dans le camp de détention de
chiottes au sud d'israël
ils ont été tués et un troisième blessé
lors d'affrontements avec leur gardien
c'est ce que vient de rapporter la
télévision israélienne
voyons maintenant les autres faits
marquants du jour l'actualité de ce
mardi
déclinée par isabelle des fleurs
arrivé aujourd'hui à bagdad des premiers
observateurs du cessez le feu de la
guerre du golfe
ces canadiens sont les premiers des 350
béret bleu non-armés une dizaine de
nationalités différentes qui doivent
assurer l'observance de la trêve entre
l'iran et l'irak
le cessez-le-feu doit être
officiellement intervenir à l'aube du
samedi 20
nous enfants et trois adultes le suédois
sont morts dans cet autobus dont les
freins ont lâché brusquement c'était
hier en norvège
le chauffeur a tenté d'arrêter son quart
contre la paroi du tunnel pour éviter
les précipices qui suivait mais le bilan
s'est avéré tragique malgré son
initiative dix autres blessés sont dans
un état critique
les 150 militaires qui aujourd'hui
encore rechercher la floridienne pauline
lafont dans un rayon de 30 kilomètres
dans le département du gard cesseront
leurs battues à la tombée de la nuit
selon leur commandant la jeune femme a
peu de chances de se trouver dans la
zone ratisser la section de recherches
de la gendarmerie de nîmes poursuit
cependant l'enquète
quatre braqueurs masqués se sont
attaqués à la succursale de la société
générale de porter ce matin fusillade
entre les gendarmes
un des gangsters à postiches est mort un
second a été blessé ainsi qu'un gendarme
et une passante
l'automobiliste prise en otage par les
deux rescapés a été relâché en fin de
matinée butin 59
ajoutez à tout cela un chiffre un
chiffre qui devrait faire réfléchir tous
les conducteurs imprudents le chiffre
des retrait du permis de conduire pour
le seul week-end du 15 août 2003
centrait en retrait de permis
2313 permis qui ont été suspendus
immédiatement au total dix sept mille pv
ont été dressés à des automobilistes qui
sont maintenant susceptible d'être
déféré devant un tribunal
la mort d'enzo ferrari nous vous en
parlions hier soir une question au
lendemain de la disparition du
commendatore et ferrari laquelle
continuer et comment il ya en effet
beaucoup d'incertitudes aujourd'hui les
tifosi et les ouvriers de l'usiné de
maranello était en deuil
reportage lionel chamoulaud le cimetière
de modène c'est ici que le common date
aurait repose depuis hier matin un
départ dans une discrétion absolue
les tifosi respecte ce choix un simple
glaïeuls rouge bien sûr sur la grille le
seul hommage pour le grand homme qui
désormais reposer auprès des siens
père mère frère et son fils dino peu ou
pas de curieux du respect seulement dans
modène sa ville située au centre de la
fertile plaine du pô le départ du plus
illustres habitants se remarque juste
part si quelques drapeaux surmonté d'un
crêpe noir le deuil dans la dignité et
la reconnaissance la grande demeure de
la famille ferrari s'est refermée sur
elle même
il a fait beaucoup pour notre ville dès
qu'ils pouvaient accomplir une bonne
heure il était présent notre
polyclinique lui doit beaucoup
c'était un grand homme l'italie a
beaucoup perdu à 20km maranello le siège
de ferrari
les usines fermées au mois d'août
quelques ouvriers de la maintenance sont
là et reste discret oui c'était vraiment
un grand homme à maranello tout et
ferrari les boutiques les restaurants et
les rues
ici on oublie pas au secteur compétition
à peine plus d'animations les formule 1
sont partis pour des essais privés à
monza la scuderia continuent hélas
toujours foule pour la compétition enzo
a disparu mais ferrari est immortel sur
l'autoroute avant modène cette sculpture
le rappelle sans transition demain film
qui sort sur les écrans bonjour
l'angoissé un film très drôle les
occasions de rire ne sont pas si
fréquentes réalisateur pierre tchernia
on voit si souvent dernier à la télé
qu'on oublie que son vrai métier sa
passion profonde c'est justement le
cinéma à la fiche de ce film ce héros
arditi et guy marchand rien des boues
présentation du film michel pascal le
héros de cette histoire est un cadre
moyennement supérieur qui travaille dans
une grande entreprise
c'est un homme modeste timide mais
toujours prêt à rendre service
michaud et un est un homme intelligent
gentil tendre mais qui vit complètement
recroquevillée dans sa coquille
parce que il a du mal à s'exprimer il a
du mal à briller en société alors qu'il
en a toutes les possibilités et au
travers de ce fait divers auxquels il va
être mêlé il va sortir de sa coquille
il va devenir un autre michaud en une
semaine
le bonhomme va être un autre il dira
plus beaux shows angoisses mes adieux
l'emploi et pour la quatrième fois
consécutive pierre tchernia fait appel à
son acteur fétiche le héros du viager et
des gaspards michaud c'est michel
serrault employés de la société de
protection stop alarme
c'est l'indestructible s'occupe des
installations sonores et cherche depuis
longtemps une alarme minuscule ont la
meilleur marché n'a pas trouvé un objet
attend les pratiques répressives parce
que les quads et bien sûr le film et
c'est exactement où je veux aller
chasser formidables parce qu'en même
temps on dans la liberté
puis cette espèce de d'assurance en
disant lui va se débrouiller avec ça il
sait exactement nous met sur des rails
et puis on le voit là si je comprends
bien vous pouvez nous annonce
aujourd'hui vous allez en faire un
cinquième dans son sac m un sixième
septième et en huitième
nous avons énormément de projets ce qui
nous manque c'est l'argent comme
d'habitude enfin on n'est pas bons
chaussée faire la quête le film c'est
bonjour langoat donc voilà fin de cette
édition du journal le prochain rendez
vous de l'information ce sera vers 23h30
à et philippe lefait vais tout de suite
bien sûr j'ai rendez vous avec laurent
cabrol souriant et optimiste pour une
météo complète
bonne soirée à d'un fort
non